lydia motika Bastianich i was born in
polar which is now Croatia it was Italy
I think that my Argent's had a
tremendous shaping of my who I am my
personality my career and so on paula is
a city in Easter Easter is open insula
that Jackson d Adriatic which is part of
Croatia now but world were to kind of
changed the whole demographics there or
the whole pole line Easter being Italian
were given to Yugoslavia as the spoils
of World War two and therefore being
ethnic Italian where the governor that
came in was communist was a tremendous
change those were my formative years
really because we ultimately my parents
he ultimately decided to escape because
once it was a communist state would
literally had to escape back to Italy so
that those years really did shake me and
sort of created my philosophy of life I
think that cooking is through centuries
has always been paraded in influenced by
different occupations in different
places just so happens that in the
northeast part of Italy where I was born
the waves as the tide of different
occupations were between the Slovak
towards the end but the
austrian-hungarian prior to that some of
the Lombards coming down and of course
the the Venetian Republic the Romans and
so on and certainly in cooking through
the recipes looking at that you can tell
what element what ingredient and what
technique I was influenced by which
asian my initial understanding maybe of
food and ultimately falling in love with
food and the production of food was in
the courtyard where my family lived with
my grandmother and my great-aunt and so
these little pockets of houses
surrounding this courtyard where
chickens and geese ran freely where we
had ducks we had rabbits goats the
gardens were in the back so to grow up
in a situation where the primary
elements of nourishment I actually been
raised and produced we had olive groves
in November we made a loyal we had wine
wine okay we had grapes growing and
ultimately in September wine was
produced we grew our own products but
also animals like the pig and again
remember the slaughter the drying and
curing of prosciutto so all of these
elements I grew up with I grew up with
the pristine flavors they're real
flavors of nature in its most simplest
form and that is I think my palate for
everything that followed what my dream
was ultimately to be a pediatrician then
it was the ship hope it was a ship that
would travel to Africa whatever and that
would bring medical assistance to needy
children and family so that was my plan
we escaped from from Yugoslavia den back
into Italy I was around ten for two
years in the aftermath of war Italy we
my parents are just tried to get a
decent job and setting was kind of
difficult so we entered in a political
refugee camp for two years and in three
years then we we stayed for two years
awaiting a visa to travel on and in 1958
the United States at that time Dwight
Eisenhower
we're provisions for recess for
political refugees people that were
escaping actually communism which we
were and we came into the United States
958 coming into United States I my
thought was of course to do this to be a
pediatrician and I went into that
direction with the sciences with the
chemistry biology and so on but somehow
I always gravitated in the food industry
a little bit to help the family and the
side works pastries restaurants
ultimately I was taken by this I met my
then husband who was in this industry
and by the age of 24 I had my first
restaurant